we have a random extra person yeah wait
we need sex
i just assumed it was up to six not that
we needed six no
it takes precisely i was wondering if we
had a watch
okay let's play with a stranger then i
guess this is gonna be a wild ride
[Music]
okay how are they finding the key cards
i don't know how to find key codes i'm
so unclear of how to do that
they just died there was a key card on a
table
someone died what and what wait a minute
okay
i don't know when that happened well
he's lying on the ground
i don't know if he's dead in china no
i'm unclear if he's dead
i'm actually pretty proud of whoever did
that if i'm being honest
yeah i'm pretty down with a toothbrush
thank you apparently i just i look
[ __ ] hot
sharla tried to kill me what what pretty
sure
what to kill me i said what because it
cut out and i only heard kill me
i think charlotte tried to kill me
charlotte was hugging me very closely
that's because i appreciate you zomb
it's very hard to tell between the two
of those and here's the thing about
charlotte is that i wouldn't know if
charlotte were trying to kill me because
she pushes me
so frequently that she could speak
because somebody jokes
i don't know what i'm doing that's you
know i just need you all to know that i
don't know what i'm doing
chat i don't know what's happening i
think i'm trying to open
a thing does it just go until someone
else joins
is this my life now oh [ __ ] god damn it
i just keep failing at that
it's hello
i failed at this a million times and i
don't know why
okay well let me try it
got it got the green card i just
inserted the green key card
go now hello here i got your key card
yes alana yes let's kill zombae okay i
just killed
marathas i think all right let's do it
where is she
oh alana anytime uh i don't know what to
do
wrong wrong button pal and pal
they were trying to kill me that's not
true i would never
get a life preserver get a light
preserver [ __ ]
preservatives
where are they life preserver oh it's
here literally
we got it we got it we got it she's
gonna push me
[ __ ] zombies trying to kill me rihanna
rihanna zombaes don't let it be safe
charlotte
okay i think i did it maybe don't make
it get away from me why are you trying
to kill charlotte
zombie you must answer for your crimes
that you definitely committed
okay i see you i see you this is messed
up
show it quick i'm just having a good
time okay
i'm just having a
[Laughter]
and i don't know what to do about it
wait wait we gotta go get oxygen
canisters
oh my god charlotte where are you hold
on shawn i know where one is
not gonna get all the
pool i drowned oh i must have just ran
out of time right at the end
because it was like the ball was moving
up but zombie kept pushing me so
it was my personal weight it must have
been pretty close because you definitely
killed me
if we find anyone else who has an
offensive username that like could even
slightly be offensive we should pretend
to be extremely outraged feminists
talk about the patriarchy
this is a new youtube series we started
calling
it's an rp like gta role plays but a
bunch of like very aggressive feminists
taking on manchester
united it's first class trouble because
we're a bunch of classy feminists yeah
good that's like uh hello
all right it's just us oh no no no oh
is this already is this already a thing
that's happening here or
what is what is this where is our stucco
i don't think this is gonna
i don't think this is gonna go well for
you buddy
[Music]
all right well you know all right is
that herbal essences
wow wow
uh five seconds ago uh-huh why are you
yep but now we're on the same team oh
you're a dude
i'm i ain't gay um no definitely not a
dude well
you hugged me anyway guys he keeps
sniffing me
oh sorry i'm trying to push teamwork
the man keeps sniffing me oh no
no i'm not i'm not a huge fan of it do
you smell
good well yeah yeah i probably did ask
for it that's fair actually
yeah yeah you can't actually all right
like he did yeah that's true
yeah you shouldn't dress like that okay
no i'm not i don't want it
right now i'm down here
i don't know about that i don't know
about any of that
well finally the patriarchy has been
thought
i love that we can't hang up and kill
someone yeah i didn't know that we had
that ability but now
and also i really wouldn't have done it
if he were a nice man but the man was
very creepy
hey you [ __ ] he was he was a real
dick attack it's rad as rad
is trying to murder me with paper plane
hey what no why don't we just
complaining i'm sorry
no it's radda's for sure i would do the
same thing if i had a paper plane
hey oh oh well
okay that was great that was great i
didn't have to kill anyone
i don't have to kill a single possum
hey you guys were right the sniffing yes
it was a little too heavy
i agree totally gave me away right off
the top yeah it was pretty creepy
i did i was thinking maybe if i like go
away crazy they might think okay
i didn't want to work with you um while
you were that creepy whatever so
but you know we want anyway i like
smelling i like smelling hair
okay well have a good one all right
what's the situation
this time that's a zombie
is it just us oh my gosh
no i think it's probably gonna be
waiting for charlotte hello explain
yourself
hello phantom hello hello there
okay you seem nice okay that's good hi
yeah i don't i don't know this game very
well we don't either cool
you are so much better than the last the
last guy was really awful so
thank you for that show it like how how
long i didn't do that oh he kept
coming he kept pretending to sniff our
hands it was nice
oh here's the keycard all right well
yeah good passive first round then
ladies and gentlemen charlotte stop
bullying the stranger
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait stop no let her go you just you
can't just be hugging random people out
here
champagne why are there so many
champagne bottles on this stupid ship
tonight what do i do with the green key
cog
charlotte charlotte you caught you
killed zombie yeah [ __ ] hell
that's why you don't trust women i'm
gonna hit ex on the other side sorry f
on the other side charlotte [ __ ] off
breathe
that the thing is you're supposed to
kill charlotte you're supposed to kill
the person
y'all but we don't want to kill
charlotte what am i pressing
hey why is this why are you doing this
also do we just like
i don't understand what we just did oh
crap crap yeah i guess we just die
uh wait i think i have a relationship
yeah
i'm dead so i have no idea
i did it oh it was re wow i was
confused even while you were murdering
me i was like could be an accident i
don't know
maybe she didn't have me i also are you
ready to be reinvited rather you want to
give it a shot
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay let's go
meet a man shall we
[Music]
and recurring betrayal can you sell me a
drink
i missed the first one i just walked
right into the slapstick joke and i'm
very entertained
oh god oh oh who's joined
hello mr rayne hello hey hello
mr rayne hello you're looking good or
miss
charlie your aim is so [ __ ] good it's
ridiculous
wow really tea bagging are you cheating
me
really oh you trash pandas it's just
funny
absolute trash panda hey mr ray hello
are you trying to do you trying to hang
out hi how are you we have a voice
hello i think your outfit's very cute
okay
[Laughter]
oh cool champagne bottle no no you don't
need it
you don't need the you don't need any of
them please oh
i'm sorry it's just funny it's like
you're sniping
like how are you doing it's just i know
i know
oh my god okay hang on hang on i'm gonna
oh i'm gonna try it somebody
sabotage the oxygen
great oh i just stuck a beer bottle into
my eye socket
yeah sometimes it do be like that
all right who is sucks
did somebody just killed a man
charlotte hey raddish why'd you sabotage
killer i didn't have no i didn't i
looked around
one more of us and one person said come
here
charizard
[Music]
i think he might be telling the truth
i'm really sorry that i'm just
siding with the man but i think he might
be right
what are we doing i'm sorry here i'll
tell you the logic are you ready she has
a sprint boost
okay what
okay
it's time to destroy charlotte
can i put myself out somebody help
please there's a uh there's a fire
extinguisher on the wall
please help us it's right here
thank you thank you thank you
but the problem is that charlotte just
has chaotic energy i don't i really
don't know about that
but it's just kind of a vibe a
toothbrush
let's go did you get it oh no
did you are you serious
[Music]
[Laughter]
why'd you do me like that
yeah you are right it was good it was
good respect um
all right you guys that's good actually
i mean you don't call it a thing
call it a day i just want to say uh to
anyone watching
don't go into a game with strangers and
make smelling sounds on your
two dollar just again
i would also recommend not making
sniffing sounds with your two hundred
dollar microphone either just
sniffing unless you're an asmr creator
in which case
please